ていた
[音楽]
1000人以上就活生とお話してきました
でまぁその中で気付いた自己分析の考え方についてお話しさせていただいて就活生が
ですね
あの結構多いんですよ自分に向いている仕事がわかりませんとか何をすればいいか
わかりませみたいなっていうしょうもない悩みことを
をする人が少しでも減って就職活動を
でまぁその先の人生を有意義にしてもらえるきっかけになればなぁと思ってお話をさせ
ていただきます
まずですねじゃあ念のため自己分析って
なにいっていう人のために
自己分析調べてきましたググってきました自己分析って調べるとこんな感じで
就職活動ってワードが絶対にセットで出てきます
日本ではねあの就活の時に面接で話す自分の強みとか弱みとかを見つけるために自己
分析をしたり自分が向いている業界とか
自分が活躍できたの食指を探すために自己分析をするという認識をされています
これがもう世間一般の認識なんですよねで牧師
冒頭の関係上約1千人以上とあってきましたけど
まあ就活生全員
就活が始まるともれなく自己分析をしますみなさんで自己分析をしてい
面接の準備何を話そうかなて準備ができたりとか自分が目指す方向性が見つかったら
も0なく全員が自己分析を止めますまそりゃそうなんですよね
だって自己分析って就職活動のために
するものって思われていますからであの仕事の関係上各企業の採用担当の方
人持参であったり社長さんと年間で500人ぐらいですかね
いろいろ話してきてその人らでも聞いてみたんですよ
じゃあ皆さんが当時就活してた頃を自己分析してどう
な話した施設してたんですかって聞いてみてももれなく全員覚えてないんですよね
何話取ったかなぁって全然覚えてないわーってなってるんですよ
それも当然でだって
書いてますけど自己分析って就活のためにするものなんでその人ら
年齢それぞれ違いますけど就活が終わって
間がいてそれは考えなかったバスれますよね当然なんですよね
で僕がふと思ったのはその自己分析を辞めていった就活生も
企業の人たちもなんか楽しくなさそうなんですよ
全かなんとなくねなんとなく楽しくなさそうやの主なそうやなあという印象を抱いてい
ました
でまぁなんやかんや言うてますけど僕自身も自己分析をしたのは就活の時だけやったん
ですよね
はいでこれ
あの僕ブレインバンクてよ自分で選んでるんですけど
ただのスケッチブックです僕このスケッチブックを
就活の時に使い始めまして何をするかというとね
就職活動をしているときにいろんな気づきとが発見があるわけですよ
で
それをこのスケッチルックに書きまくるんですよね
何を感じたかとか何を思ったかとかで就活以外のところでも本を読んだりへネットで
ニュースを見たりとか
人と話していく中で自分が感じたこと思ったことを書きまくるんですよ
で
これってあの割と高くだけなんで簡単やと思われるんですけど割りとちょっと難しくて
やってわざわざ自分の考えとか重いとかを文字にすることっても来なかったんですよね
人生において
でしてみようとするとここまでは出てくるんですよ
自分が考えてることってでも何て書いたんやろみたいななんていうかなーって言って
なかなかできないんですよね
でそれをどんどん高まぁ頑張って頑張って最低1日に1回寝る前に30分まとってその
一重たこと感じたことをブーバーって書き出して言って自分と向き合う時間をとったん
ですよね
でこれをを毎日し続けてもう
たまにはもう一日中これ回転茶を買ってくれる日もあったんですけどそれのおかげも
あってか
就職活動で一切困らなかったんですよ
企業の人にじゃああなたの強みを教えてくださいとか
岩見なんですからに頑張ってきましたかとかどう考えてますかっていうのをぼくこれつ
だって自分の考えを深堀り続けまくったので
むしろ聞いてくれるんですか話していいですか
ぐらいの感じで僕は就活教えたんですよ
なので一切困ることはなくて
選考辞退はどんどん甘く入ったんですけど何か
なんかピンとくるものがなくて4回生の時は入社すると決めませんでした
なんかパッとせんなーおもんないなぁと思ってもう1年してみようと思って
もう1年就職浪人の形を選びました
で
その後もですね企業のあの選考は落ち着いていったんですけどいろんなところに足を
運んでいろんな大人の人と話して自分の思いをぶつけまくっていろんなところに来足を
運んで行ってしていく中で僕であったんですよね翌年の就活が始まる前なんでまぁ
年明け1月2月ぐらいにどう
をしてもこれがしたいとこれはどうしても実現したいというものに出会ったんですよ
何かというと北6条見た就活を楽しんでる人間あったんですけど周りを見るとねみんな
が楽しくなるそうなんですよ
なんか色々聞かれる答えられない子はいーとか音がしたいことまだ見つかってないとか
楽しくなるそうなんですよねで僕
むちゃむちゃバカなんですよあのしゃべり方でば
出るかもしれませんけど僕めちゃめちゃバカなんですけど就活を僕は無茶また楽しめ
ましたということは僕以外の人たちもどこかには就活を楽しむ方法
知ってる人いるんじゃないか
そういった人らが楽しむ方法をどの子新しい仕組みをつくって共有していけばいい
みんな就活楽しめるんじゃないのかなと思って最近
まあ自分で起業したりとかフリーランスとか言われてますけどどうせほぼの人は
まだまだ就活をするであろう
で避けられないのであれば楽しめる仕組みがあったほうがええんちゃうかと思って僕は
それをしようと決めたんですよね
で
その翌年の就活の際は人材系の会社に入って3年くらい
その採用のことを勉強して起業しようと
決めましてみなさんあのきっと聞いたことあると思うんですけど
就活の際でみんなが使うなんとかナビみたいなあの有名なところあるじゃないですか
2つの n ナビみたいなのかた方にあの
内定とりましてもらいましてで去年の10月に
内定式に出席してきましたで
その3日後ですねあのその時僕も卒業してたんで
2年目あったんでバイトしかすることなかったんですよ入社まで半年間で僕
起業するとかなんかこの会社で一番取ってやるとかあむちゃむちゃ大口叩いてたんで
あのやることやらなあかんなぁと思って入社までの半年間あのバイ
とするんじゃなくてどっかの企業に入ってはインターンとして社会勉強をして少しでも
成長しておこうと思いがありまして
内定式の翌日から大阪のとある人材系のベンチャー企業で働き始めました
で
そこでもちゃまちゃ驚いたんですけどあの僕がやりたいと思ってた事とか僕の考え方と
か全く一致する環境があったんですよ
ここやと思って
もういてもたってもいられなくなりましてあの内定先には申し訳ないですけど
内定式を出たもその3日後にあっすいませんえんってあのやりたいことが見つかっ
ちゃいましてみたいな形でちゃんとあのお伝えして
でーもー
体が勝手に動いてましたね社長のところに行ってあの
ここで働きたいですと雇ってくださいって言ってその翌月
去年11月からそこで社員となペア働いきました
その当時の僕こんな感じですテンション的にはむちゃむちゃ楽しいと自分のやりたい
ことが見つかってそれが叶えられる環境があってそこで働けるって
無茶魔女最高やったんですよねで休みの日ももう朝から晩まで仕事のことを考えて
ずっと仕事仕事でした
で
働き始めて約半年ぐらい経ってゴールディニー口がきまして
であの久々に僕入社してから友達とかと飲みに行くと全くなくなったんですよ
一生仕事しとったんでで久々にゴールデンウィーク初日に大学の友人と予定を合わせ
ましてご飯食べに行きまして a
お話してたんですけどあの友人に言われたんですよね
睦明って言うんですけど亮からこんなに口聞いたことないとアキラの口から口を聞いた
ことが無かったのに変わったなって言われたんですよ
その時はっとして持って今まで誰とご飯行く時も僕ばかり
んでウチはまず夢を語ってたんですよこうやって就活かえんねこうやってやってくれ
こう考えてんねんって言ってたのに
思えばもう今の会社しんどいわーとかあの人が同校でストレスがあってややは解釈も
しんどいわって僕が一番
なりたくなかったなんかおもんなさそうがな大人に綺麗に僕なってたんですよ
それにあの友人とご飯に行って気付かされましてそれがゴールでいる初日です
でこれはやばいとさすがにダサいとあんだけ大口叩いてて大手決定岡野泣かせて
ベンチャー入ってこれはカンカンと思っていろんな人に相談をして一人で考えて
で気づいたんですよね
なんでこうなったのかこんな感じですぼく
入社半年たたこんな感じスポ根ペンションもう会社行くんやって
で
そこでゴールデンウィークを使ってめちゃめちゃ考えまして気づいたんですけどあの
これをね
今日皆さんに一番伝えたいんですけど僕手段が目的化してしまってたんですよ
手段が目的化僕の目的って
さっきもちょっとお話しましたけど就活を変える新しい仕組みをつくる新しい当たり前
を作ろうと思ってその目的の為の手段としてこのベンチャーに入ることを決めたのに
日々の忙しい仕事とかまあなかなか成果が出なくて
社長に怒られてとか焦りとかからもう目の前の
仕事をこなすことに精一杯になってて本来の目的を考えることを
忘れとったんですよ
はい
ずっとそればっかりもういやいやこれやらな怒られても怒られてまうって言ってだから
自分がどこに向かっているのかもわからなくなって違う持ちは楽しくなかったんです
毎日が
そうなんということも気づいてなかったんですけどでこの手段が目的化してしまって
るって
就活生にも当てはまるんじゃないのかなと思ってて
就活ってあの本来の目的は自分の理想とか叶えた夢があって人それぞれ違いますけど
起業したいとか
いいお嫁さんなりたいといろいろあると思うんですけどその目的を実現するための大学
の次のへステージを選ぶ集団が就活だと思うんですけど
僕が千人以上あってきた就活生ほぼほぼが初めはそういう女語るんですよね
こうなりたいと思っていますっていうんですけどだんだん周りの友達が内定もらうとか
あの
も子もないからどうしようとか面接ショットをして自信なくなってきて
とりあえず内定が欲しいとない手を取らなきゃいけないっていうその手段
であるはずの内定を取ることが目的化して言ってたんですよね
見てる感じだから楽しくなそうなんやなと思って
就活生も僕も本来の目的を忘れてたんですよ
考えてないから考えることを放棄しとったんですよ
だから楽しくなかったじゃあどうすればいいかって考えたんですけど
むちゃむちゃ簡単で
考えればいいんですよね
考えればいいだけでじゃあ何をするかというとあの北
その就活の時にしていたブレインバンクを取り出してきましてその日から必ず毎日
どんだけ忙しくても30分はその日感じたこととか
自分がなぜここにいるのかとか何をしたいのかというのをちゃんと向き合う時間を作っ
たんですよ
で
ブレインバンクと同時に始めたのがブログ
ブログを書き始めましたでより言語化することの精度を高めようと思ってバーブレイン
バンクだと書き出しているだけで見るのは僕だけなんで僕がわかればいいぐらいなん
ですけど
ブログにして誰が見てもちゃんと分かるようにちゃんと伝わるように
文の中でも
腑に落として文字にしていくっていうことをしてもう
常に考え続けました何があってもその物事を表面上だけ受け取るんじゃなくて自分は
どう思うのかとかどう考えるのかというのを考えてさらに言葉にするってことを
繰り返して繰り返して思いついたことはどんどん行動していくようにしました
考えた結果北
はじめに言うと目的就活に革命を起こす行ったんですけどそもそもこれって僕なんでし
たかったかなみたいな
その週間で革命を起こす目的は何なのかなって考えたら正直言ってボク
パターンに目立ちたかったんですよ有名になりたかったんですよ
でただて有名になりたくてその時混み合ったのが就活にあったので
者就活を変えて有名になろうと思って
行ったんですよねその目的に気づけました
そうアウトプットする時間をつくりましてでやりたいことで変わると思うんですよ
そりゃそうですよね始められたことがあったとしても日々どんどんいろんな経験をして
いくわけで
むしろ変わらなおかしいと思うんですよで行ってみんとわからんこともあるじゃない
ですか
これがしたくてここやと思って入ってみて実際こんな感じかーってなることがあると
もんですよねでそれをどんどん考えていった結果僕
皆さん驚かないで聞いてください僕先月会社辞めてきました
驚かないですねすいません
あっあるとでも搾取徘徊写メてきまして
でまぁ周りにはもちもち言われましたお前普通は3年ぐらい働かなあかんでとかやめて
と思い何も出来ひんでみたいなこと言われたんですけどたしかに信念があってその決め
た場所でやり抜くのは素敵なことだと思うんですけど
一度決めたからそこやらなアカンっていうのは
僕的にはちょっと考えていることを放棄してるんじゃないのかなって思う部分もあった
んですよ
だからやめましていいですね
確かにあの新卒での就活って一生に一度きりなんで不安もあるでしょうして初めての
ことやから緊張もするでしょうけどあの
入ってみないとわからないんでその悩むことないんじゃないのかなと思ってて楽しん
だらいいと思うんですよ
新卒でどこでも受けれるんでペッカ寝床をたくさん観に行っていろんな業界目に入って
楽しんだらいいと思うんですよ
もし入って違うなと思っても辞めればいいじゃないですか止めたと体
死なないんで別に生きていけるんで
はいなんでどんどん挑戦していってやっていけばいいと思うんですよねはい
でおくこんなちょっ友達に作ってもらってめちゃめちゃ出さないですけど僕も何も有名
じゃないし何も話すことないけど僕こうやって場所を勝手に借りて講演会やって学生6
人くらい来て僕がいっしょゆめ語るっていう講演会
たりしたんですよねやりたいことなんて本気で思っていればどこでもできるんすよね
いろんな言い訳作って忙しいとかちょっと子やった経験がないとかよってあの止めて
いる人が多いですけどどこでもできるんですよ
で何かと言いますと僕にとっては自己分析って就職活動の為って世間一般に認識されて
ますけどそうじゃないと思ってて
自己分析をして自己分析が始めるきっかけが就活であったぐらいなんですね僕的には
で自分が次進むべき環境を怒って決めたそこからが本番やと思っててそこから今まで
学生じゃ経験できなかったような経験を社会に入って
いろいろして押していくわけじゃないですかいろんな価値観とか考えとか新しい場も
たくさん入ってきていろいろ学んでいくんのに
そこからさらにじゃあこの場所で何ができるのか
このバスでいいのかどの考えていかなきゃいけないのになぜか皆さん
就活が終わると自己分析を止めてしまう
ねあーなんかなと思って大丈夫かと思ってますはい
で掃除機就職活動って自己分析とか終章活動半年ぐらいなんですよね
考えてわかるじゃないですか半年間でたかだか自己分析って言って机に向かって小学校
の時に私こんな行った子がこんなことをしたとかだけで半年間で自分のやりたい仕事と
か
6艇
環境とか見つから理由なくないですか見つかるともいるでしょうけどねぇ
ほほうの人は見つからないと思うんですよそれで悩んでいるのになぜか止めちゃう謎や
なって僕は就活を8自己分析は就活のためじゃなくて人生において理想に向かって常に
し続けていくもやと僕はもう
入っています